es un criminal de guerra un comentario
improvisado con el potencial de alterar
permanentemente las relaciones entre
eeuu y rusia
la invasión de ucrania está en su cuarta
semana cada día trayendo nuevas muertes
de civiles a manos de las fuerzas rusas
las declaraciones improvisadas del
presidente estadounidense joe biden ya
lo han puesto en aprietos en el pasado
pero esta vez la casa blanca insiste en
que no fundamente dura de pata
los comentarios del presidente hablan
por sí mismos hablo con el corazón y
hablando desde lo que había visto en la
televisión que son acciones bárbaras de
un dictador brutal a través de su
invasión de un país extranjero el
kremlin rápidamente denunció lo que
llamó retórica inaceptable e
imperdonable pero son los nuevos envíos
de armas de eeuu los que probablemente
tendrán un impacto más tangible en los
planes de moscú el miércoles el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
pronunció un emotivo discurso en vídeo
ante los legisladores estadounidenses
invocando el 11 de septiembre pearl
harbor ya martin luther king en su
petición de ayuda
y aunque ucrania no obtendrá una zona de
exclusión aérea aplicada por la otan que
se les que quiere recibir a 800 millones
de dólares en nueva ayuda militar
estadounidense
incluyendo 2000 ya billings 6000 at4 y
800 misiles stinger que han demostrado
su eficacia en la destrucción de
blindados y helicópteros rusos también
recibirán un cargamento de drones
armados switchblade misiles portátiles y
ligeros que pueden permanecer más de 30
minutos sobre el campo de batalla para
encontrar un objetivo
para ayudar a ucrania a defender sus
cielos a mayor altura washington también
planea organizar la entrega de sistemas
de misiles antiaéreos s-300 de la era
soviética de los aliados de la otan en
el este europeo